on dit souvent que le ver de terre est
un allié des agriculteurs et que sa
présence est un signe que le sol est en
bonne santé mais en forêt c'est une
toute autre histoire
ah ouais il est en a beaucoup de choses
ici dans ces terres expérimentales de
Sainte-Anne de Bellevue Joan welln est
en mission waouh ça c'est excellent
aussi cette chercheuse de l'université
mais Guil analyse la présence et
l'impact des vers de terre en
agriculture beaucoup
facilement voir d'abord s'il y a des
vers de terre et comment ces invertébrés
change la composition d'un sol
en bois quelque chose très intéressant à
voir le soir qui était travaille par les
vers de terre et on peut voir où il
ferme les déjections sur le service de
soi et non maman c'est comme c'est comme
ici donc il prendre avec son nourriture
les plantes et prendre un peu de soie et
le mélange complètement ensemble et il
fait quelque chose de nouveau qui est
très stable il est stable contre le
précipitation il est stable contre le
bon donc
ces recherches démontrent que les vers
de terre peuvent aider à fournir de 10 à
20% des nutriments nécessaires aux
plantes et que cela favorise une
augmentation de la croissance de 20 à
30%. et leur présence pourrait être une
solution pour réduire la quantité
d'engrais de synthèse bref les vers de
terre sont bons pour l'agriculture et
l'agriculture favorisent la
prolifération des
[Musique]
versants à 3 verres de terre par mètre
carré
et si on trace mètre carré c'est une
distance comme ça jusqu'à moi donc c'est
pas une très grosse espace ici mais dans
cette petite espace
300 verres de terre
[Musique]
malgré leur grande présence partout les
vers de terre ne sont pas indigènes en
Amérique du Nord la grande glaciation
qui a recouvert le continent il y a des
milliers d'années à éradiquer la
population naturelle de vers de terre
seuls quelques espèces ont survécu dans
des régions épargnées de la glaciation
comme Ukon les vers de terre sont par la
suite réapparus partout en Amérique du
Nord en raison de la colonisation
européenne
[Musique]
les petits pots avec les plantes les
outils etc et parmi les choses qui le
portaient sont aussi les verbes de terre
eux des vers de terre sont petits ils
s'apparente à des graines ils peuvent se
coincer partout et une petite anecdote
la distribution des vers de terre a
aussi suivi l'origine de la colonisation
[Musique]
une espace que on trouve ici au Québec
c'est une qui est très nombreuse en
Bretagne en France et si on va à
l'intérieur par contre on voit un autre
sort qui vient de l'Angleterre donc on
trouve les vers de terre les espaces
distinctes différentes à partir de
origines des gens
si la présence des vers de terre est
bénéfique pour les sols en agriculture
ces invertébrés ne sont pas souhaitables
partout
on croit à tort que les vers de terre
sont toujours bénéfiques pour la santé
des sols et ça ces problématiques
analyse la présence de verres de terre
ici il y a une population indigène qui
date d'avant la glaciation donc elle est
naturelle mais ce qui intéresse les
chercheurs c'est de savoir s'il y a
d'autres espèces non-exigènes
transportées par les humains et surtout
si les vers de terre se retrouvent en
forêt
en Amérique du Nord lorsque nous
introduisons des vers de terre non
indigènes dans ces forêts naturelles
nous constatons une perte générale de
biodiversité nous voyons une baisse du
nombre d'organismes vivants Isla affecte
aussi les plantes
il provoque d'énormes changements dans
la structure des sols
la décomposition est lente dans les
forêts il y a des couches organiques
bien définies lorsque vous introduisez
des vers de terre ils accélèrent les
taux de décomposition et consomment plus
rapidement les matières organiques
[Musique]
ou le verseauteur
Kevin
contenu des effets qu'on les verres de
terre européennes sur les écosystèmes
nous sommes préoccupés par l'arrivée des
verres sauteurs car il est connu qu'il
consomme plus rapidement les couches
organiques des sols
en plein centre du Nouveau-Brunswick la
biologiste Erin Cameron traque ce vert
qui est apparu ici
l'an dernier ils ont trouvé ces verses
hauteurs pour la première fois dans les
Maritimes nous sommes donc revenus cette
année pour déterminer où il se trouve
dans la cour et s'ils se sont propagés
depuis
quelques hypothèses expliquent comment
ils auraient pu être introduits ici il y
a le déplacement de certaines plantes ou
de la terre qui aurait pu être achetées
dans une pépinière les vers de terre
peuvent également être transportés sur
les bandes de roulement des pneus grâce
à leurs œufs ou leur cocon
[Musique]
le ver de terre asiatique est
reconnaissable par cette anneau il est
aussi beaucoup plus furtif ce qui
explique pourquoi on le surnomme
verseauteur on retrouve ce verre de
façon naturelle au Japon il aurait fait
son apparition en Amérique du Nord en
Californie au milieu du 19e siècle et a
ensuite fait son chemin ailleurs aux
États-Unis grâce aux activités humaines
dans le nord-est du pays il prolifèrent
déjà depuis une bonne vingtaine d'années
Chris
dans nord-est des États-Unis en quelque
chose de moins beau et de moins riche
place
dans les forêts du Vermont Joseph goret
mène des études de qualité de sol pour
comprendre l'impact des vers asiatiques
très épaisse de matière organique pas
seulement des feuilles mais aussi des
feuilles légèrement décomposées ou très
décomposés et là il n'y a plus rien que
ce terreau créé par les vers de terre
cela signifie que certaines des plus
petites plantes ne peuvent pas germer
ici et donc ça enlève vraiment de la
biodiversité dans cette forêt
pour nous montrer la différence il nous
transporte dans un parc d'état où les
vers asiatiques ne sont pas encore
arrivés
c'est une forêt typique du Nord-Est elle
est très similaire à celle qu'on a
visité précédemment mais regardez il y a
beaucoup plus de sous-bois ici il y a
plus d'espèces que dans l'autre forêt
quand vous marchez vous sentez que c'est
spongieux vous le sentez sous vos pieds
le sol est plus mou alors que dans
l'autre forêt vous ne ressentez pas cela
c'est presque une surface dure
un verre de terre qu'il soit asiatique
ou européen se reproduit à vitesse grand
V comme il était amaphrodite il possède
des organes génitaux mâles et femelles
la prolifération est donc rapide et ne
nécessite que très peu d'individus
[Musique]
un verre de terre peut produire jusqu'à
alors il faut faire la multiplication
60 x 60 3600 et ainsi de suite année
après année
[Musique]
le verre de terre est une espèce
envahissante sa facilité à s'implanter
partout en est une preuve
il est le grand ami des jardiniers et
des agriculteurs mais il fait craindre
le pire pour nos forêts
the best way to contour stop la
meilleure façon de les contrôler et de
les empêcher de sortir des pépinières ou
des jardins nous avons tous notre part
de responsabilité
nous devons trouver des moyens de ne pas
les transporter dans les forêts c'est
comme ça qu'il se propage
après analyse il y a au moins un soupir
de soulagement
[Musique]
nous savions que les vers de terre
commençaient apparaître au Yukon surtout
autour des villes c'est pourquoi nous
enquêtons là-dessus mais nous avons
trouvé peu de verre en forêt c'est une
très bonne nouvelle cela signifie que
nous pouvons limiter leur propagation et
ainsi maintenir ses forêts dans le même
état qu'elles se trouvent depuis plus de
10.000 ans
[Musique]